today's classic interview is with none
other than former Minnesota governor
Jesse Ventura he joined me a couple of
months before the 2012 election he went
off on Mitt Romney he went off on a
whole bunch of different topics this was
a really really popular interview in
2012 one of the most popular interviews
of that year and as we're getting back
into the pre-election type interviews I
thought we would go back and check out
this interview and you know Jesse
Ventura has really changed his sort of
public persona since this interview he's
gone much more in the direction of the
conspiratorial he had that TV show about
conspiracy theories he is now doing a
show I believe for aura TV from his
Mexican sort of bungalow sort of thing
where he's off the grid as he talks
about I think the show is actually
called off the grid a lot of changes in
Jesse Ventura not only over the last ten
years but since we did this interview
which we will check out now welcome back
to the show joining me is former
Minnesota governor Jesse Ventura the new
book is Democrats and Republicans no
more gangs in government governor always
a pleasure to speak with you first thing
or the book this is I think the third or
fourth time we've had you on the show we
were kind of making fun of I guess it
was a year or two ago when Sarah Palin
wrote her book and we knew she didn't
really write it it was really her
co-writer what's the the writing process
like for you I know you wrote this with
dick Russell do you tell him the stories
do you guys work on these things
together how does it work well it works
dick we fill rights for each other I I
don't have the patience to do the
research so dick Russell is a fun
fantastic researcher so he will find out
all the information he does all the
research work and then you know I lived
the winters down in Mexico and dick also
comes down to Mexico so he will come
down to Mexico and the two of us will
sit together for probably three weeks or
so or a month and he'll bring all the
research and we'll write the book
together you know he he he does
essentially most of the writing you know
and the research part of it though we do
work completely together on it that's
why I give him billing all the time
because
I certainly couldn't do the research and
some of the things that dick does and of
course dick can't get the publicity or
the name recognition that I have so of
course in the book you continue the idea
that both Democrats and Republicans or
don't really have Americans best
interest in mind and you've we've talked
before about how you think we shouldn't
even have political parties right now
when I talk to a lot of people they like
the idea of we really need a strong
third party and my concern with that is
wouldn't that party as soon as it
becomes viable just also be taken over
by the same corporate interest we see
taking over gentlemen Republican
absolutely you're completely correct any
third party in which to be viable and
compete would have to sell their soul
they would have they would have to
you're exactly corrected and then
instead of having a two-headed monster
you'd have a three-headed monster you
know that's why I advocate the
abolishment of political parties let's
make them political action committees
and one of the big things we could do to
start off I mean it won't happen because
it requires the Democrats and the
Republicans to do it and they're not
about to do it why don't they remove all
as I say all gang names and gang symbols
from the election ballot for just a name
of the candidate down see they make it
so if you're conservative
you don't have to know the name of the
candidate you walked into the voting
booth and you look for the main
Republican if you're liberal you do the
same thing you don't have to know the
name in the candidate you just look for
the word Democrat
well let's remove those from the ballot
then it becomes imperative for the voter
to educate he or she herself or himself
they would have to educate what does
John Smith stand for right now you don't
have to do that at all because they all
people do is vote party line and if
you're conservative or if you're liberal
Democrat party line and remove them that
would be a huge step in the process but
getting that done will never happen
because and it does not matter which
rich one you elect because they're all
bought and sold by corporate America
today
last time you were on you said some nice
things about Ron Paul and I'm fascinated
to know from you we just saw that his
son Rand Paul has chosen to endorse Mitt
Romney on the Republican side even
though technically Ron Paul is still a
candidate what's your reaction to that
I'm I'm outraged over it how could
someone go against his own father really
and endorse you know you don't lie I'll
tell you honestly you know why Mitt
Romney should not be a president I can
think of probably 50 reasons but what's
yours I could give you one okay you know
I don't want someone in the highest
office that believes in magic underwear
are you familiar with the Mormon
religion yeah oh yeah so do you believe
that Mormon Mormonism is a cult I don't
care if it's a car I think they all are
I'm an atheist I don't for take to any
religion I I believe in the teachings of
George Carlin now number George Carlin
of course let's say was a whitewashed
atheist George said I worship the Sun
because the Sun comes up to me if the
Sun gives me heat that gives me food it
gives me everything I need and like
George would say and most of all it
comes up every morning and I can see it
that gives it great credibility but so
much if you are the Mormonism is a
concern to you well don't get me wrong
people can believe what they want
I'm very libertarian if people want to
believe in religion and they want to
believe there's a higher being up there
that open overlords all of us and that
every Sunday we have to pay homage to
him fine if you want to believe that but
this magic underwear stuff is the most
ridiculous thing I've heard to wear the
underwear has to be blessed and you can
own and it only has openings where where
the part that conceive a child can come
in contact right you have sex how
ridiculous is that it's interesting for
sure Wow to me it's its borders on silly
ridiculous and I want a president that
believes be us like that hey let me
throw a few questions at you that I got
from the audience
Roker wants me to ask you about this
story out of Florida
we're kind of led by Governor Rick Scott
we've started to see mostly liberal
voters being removed from the voter
rolls and told they have to prove their
citizenship a tactic which will clearly
help Republicans in Florida what do you
think of these voter suppression tactics
I think they're awful
voting should be made easy we we in
Minnesota have same-day registration
right well you can register that day and
vote and the voting fraud is so you
might get one or two you know it makes
no difference
voting should be made easy not difficult
and that's what you that's the problem
you have they want to now make you jump
through all these hurdles to vote and if
they don't want large turnouts you know
this governor of Florida I heard him a
little bit earlier on CNN when I was
here and he says we want everyone to
vote we want this he's lying through his
teeth they don't want people to vote
because the less people that vote the
easier it is to control the elections
and you know don't let the Democrats off
the hook either it does not matter you
know with the with the Supreme Court
ruling that money is free speech and
that corporations are people right now
they can accept all these corporation
donations they don't even have to tell
us where they dot them from I got a
solution you want to hear mine yeah I
think every presidential candidate
should be required to wear a NASCAR
racing suit whenever they're in public
and I say that because when you watch
Jimmie Johnson or some of the great
NASCAR race drivers look at their suits
they have all their sponsors on them
it's full disclosing yeah so disclosure
that way we as voters can look at them
and find out who owns them find out
who's going to get favorite you know
stuff from them they've these two
parties have built a system based
completely on bribery bribery
if you bribe the elected official or you
bribe the democrat or republican party
you'll get what you want now if we do
that in the private sector we go to jail
how come we allow them to use bribery in
our elections and you know it doesn't
end there
you know logic if we lie to the
government we go to jail if they lie to
us nothing happens how come the street
doesn't go both ways
governor irene wants to get your
thoughts on these attacks that we're
seeing on women's reproductive rights
access to contraception and and just
what we're seeing but at an incredible
in an incredible number of states but
also even proposals from federal
legislators do you think this is
motivated by Republicans thinking it
will help them win elections is it is
are we going back in our opinion about
what women's rights should be what do
you make of it well women have always
been oppressed you know days days you
know what what was it dial what I
remember the great record by John lemon
you know and now women are always
oppressed and you know if they can
oppress any group they will do it and
it's ridiculous but do you think that
the government can have control over
your reproduction that that government
let's take it a step with gay marriage
what right does government have to tell
you who to fall in love with and who to
marry and and their holding and what
people need to understand is you have to
have elected people with courage if you
put a civil rights issue up for a vote
it's generally the majority deciding an
issue for a minority well if you do that
if we put it up for vote we'd still have
slavery sure we don't even know that
worked for you for free we wouldn't even
have an integrated military wouldn't we
no we would not in the presence of you
if you have politicians to say well
we're gonna put this up then let the
people decide what a crock of crap
because the people you can't allow the
majority to make a decision for a
minority when it's civil rights like I
said if we allow that we still out
slaves okay a couple more things to
touch on in our limited time Dennis
wants to know in a cage match between
Obama and Romney who do you think would
win I think I take my politics more
serious but a silly question like that
yeah I thought it was a silly question
but I'd rather go all out there you know
yeah it's fine but you know people if
they want to make fun of my wrestling
career in wrestling itself fine but let
me put it in this context with the
Democrats and Republicans it is like pro
wrestling in front of the cameras and in
front of the media they portray to you
that their adversaries who do not like
each other behind the scenes they're all
doing deals together they're all they
all have the same motivation so they're
just under Sarah's power so you're
saying is basically we're putting on a
show to kind of vein this idea that
they're pushing for their side even
though behind the scenes they're just
broke absolutely absolutely that's well
that's what goes on it's just it's worse
than pro wrestling there's pro wrestling
is entertainment this is supposed to be
government okay and Robert wants to know
what's the single greatest threat to our
freedom today
ah the single greatest threat to our
freedom the Democrats and Republicans so
you think just the political system
itself it's yeah because it's it's based
on bribery they're taking away our
freedoms left and right
I think the war on terrorism is a
complete joke and a fraud do you know
that more people die in one week some
drunk driving in the United States and
died in terrorism in a year absolutely
yet we spend billions of dollars
fighting the supposed war on terror you
know and it's the lockdown here's the
thing that has me scared too
the lockdown of America and our rights
all this crap at the airport with the
TSA and all that you know that I sued
them yeah in federal court for my fourth
amendment rights reasonable
search-and-seizure
and the judge ruled that she didn't have
jurisdiction right that's outrageous
she's a federal judge and it's a
constitutional question that's what they
do with every case because they won't
allow you in court because I would win
and if I won that would open up a bag of
worms on them and this lockdown of
America well they're making us
comfortable being searched
they now of
say have you heard this they have what I
call PSA Viper teams Tennessee is the
first state to folk' them they'll pull
you over on the highway and search you
without ninety probable cause yet we
didn't cover that yeah yeah now that's
what I feel the most is the fact that
our government is turning fascist if
it's not already fascist and it's the
lockdown of America they're taking our
freedoms away remember when George Bush
made the quote they attacked us because
they're jealous of our freedom you
remember that yeah yeah so what we still
alternative now they're gonna take our
freedom I guess to make us safe so we
won't get attacked any marketers will
have no freedom so they won't be jealous
about exactly nobody will be jealous
than theirs anymore yeah because we'll
have no freedom
the scariest thing happening right now
is seeing the erosion of the Bill of
Rights I mean when you have the wall
street protesters whether you agreed
with them or not you should have
supported their right to protest because
some day you may want to protest
you can't protest in the United States
anymore they'll bring out dogs they'll
bring our pepper spray they'll do all
sorts of stuff to you Fourth Amendment
reasonable search-and-seizure that is
gone so to put in a nutshell I see the
scariest thing happening right now is
that we have no bill of rights anymore
all right the book is Democrats and
Republicans course former governor Jesse
Ventura you can also find out more at we
ain't got time to bleed calm pleasure as
always governor thank you I always
appreciate thanks for having me on and
I'd like to add this if I may in short I
was supposed to do the Don Imus show
their producers were all excited wanted
me on the show they asked for five songs
that I'd like played on my introductions
and I chose Rage Against the Machine by
with Tom Morello right BAM there was
band on the build-up to the Iraq war and
through the Iraq war
I must went ballistic and won't have me
on now is that true when were you
supposed to be on I was supposed to be
on this week and you're not doing it now
because of your song choice well I don't
know if it's song choices or because
you know the book itself but Imus
himself big tough dhamma don imus who
who said those racist remarks about the
Rutgers women's basketball team if you
remember of course uh she won't have
beyond au in peril all right well no I'm
glad you mentioned that it's uh it's
interesting stuff and we'll have your
welcome here anytime governor so thanks
again well thank you I appreciate it but
the windows closing on me FoxNews won't
have me on and neither will MSNBC okay
well well that's uh we were people will
hear that now so thank you okay thank
you have a good one take care bye-bye